زوجان في كاليفورنيا يرفعان دعوى قضائية ضد
عيادة خصوبة بدعوى أن تلك
العيادة زرعت الجنين الخطأ
في أمتين مختلفتين في إجراء التلقيح الاصطناعي
، ونتيجة لذلك ، أنجبت كلتا المرأتين
وتربيتا
أطفالًا لم يكونوا أطفالًا بيولوجيًا
لعدة أشهر
فقدوا الطفل المولود منك.  تعرف
على الطفل الجيني أنك لا
تعرف حتى الآن
أنه كابوس مستحيل حقًا
بدلاً من إرضاع طفلي رضاعة طبيعية ، لقد أرضعت طفلاً
وارتبطت بطفل ،
وقد أُجبرت لاحقًا على التخلي عن
إليزابيث كوهين من CNN للانضمام إلينا الآن ،
أعني أنه مجرد
حتى  فكر في العائلتين في
هذا الموقف بشكل صحيح ،
ما أعطى الزوجين إشارة في
البداية إلى أن هذا قد لا يكون طفلهما
، يبدو أنهما عرفوا قريبًا أن
إيريكا لاحظوا أنه عندما
ولد هذا الطفل ، لم يكن هذا الطفل عادلاً ، فقد كان
هذا الطفل  أغمق بكثير من
الابنة التي كان لديهم بالفعل ، لذلك كان لهذا
الطفل بشرة أغمق وكان شعره أغمق
ولذا يبدو أنهم
يشتبهون في ذلك  في شيء لم يكن
صحيحًا تمامًا عندما كان الطفل يبلغ من العمر شهرين ،
أظهر الاختبار الجيني أن هذا لم يكن
طفلهم وراثيًا في ثلاثة أشهر
، اكتشفوا أن جنينهم قد
تم استخدامه وأن زوجًا آخر قد
أنجبوا ابنتهم البيولوجية وفي عمر
أربعة أشهر  التقى هؤلاء الأزواج
وعاد الأطفال إلى والديهم البيولوجيين ،
لم يكن هذا أمرًا مدمرًا
للآباء الذين يقولون إنهم يقولون إنه
كان مدمرًا أيضًا لطفلهم الأكبر
، فلنستمع إلى محامي الوالدين
آدم وولف
للطفل البالغ من العمر خمس سنوات  أن دافني
وألكسندر عانوا من هذا الأمر كان
مؤلمًا ، لقد ارتبطت
بأختها الرضيعة التي كانت تعرفها ، وفي عمر أربعة
أشهر لذلك الطفل ، تم أخذها
بعيدًا
عن ابنتهما الكبرى
فجأة كانت لا تثق في
أنها لم تكن غاضبة  عناق أو تقبيل والديها ،
أعتقد أن هذا رد فعل مفهوم ولكن
بالنسبة لفتاة تبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات ، من
المدمر
الآن أن تضع في اعتبارك أن هناك عشرات
منك  رمال الأطفال الذين يولدون في الولايات المتحدة من
خلال التلقيح الاصطناعي كل عام ، هذا
حدث غير عادي للغاية بقدر ما نعلم أنه
كان هناك عدد قليل من الحالات الأخرى المبلغ عنها ولكن
كانت هناك شكاوى من أن
صناعة الخصوبة يجب أن تكون أفضل في
اتباع قواعدها الخاصة أو غير ذلك  إنهم
بحاجة إلى مواجهة المزيد من اللوائح التنظيمية erica jim